投資朋友大家好
今天台灣股市好扯喔
三大重點我要一次告訴你
台股大跌又量縮
如何解讀 散戶都不回來了嗎
我告訴大家
我等一下親自唱一首歌讓大家醒來
哲哲當分析師20年來
告訴你台灣股市怎麼解讀
用這首歌來告訴你
第二個 台指期大跌近千點
破千點了
暴漲暴跌是空頭嗎
第三個 美伊衝突升溫了
升息機率大增怎麼辦
好恐怖 這個行情真的恐怖
導播有沒有覺得很恐怖
有 超恐怖的
大家都覺得很恐怖 沒有關係
壓壓驚 壓壓驚
大家覺得很恐怖
可是恐怖的是為什麼
因為要升息了
大家會緊張這個行情 你看
現在這個股票 很多股票
景碩也好
還有台達電也好 是不是
你看台達電跌成這樣子
最恐怖的是什麼 國巨
怎麼一會漲 一會跌
很多人不了解到底發生什麼事情
怎麼會這樣
台灣股市今天會不會再繼續跌
這一波的47000點是不是一個關卡
會不會跌破40000點
我等一下一次講個夠
因為台達電也跌 國巨也跌
天啊 聯電也跌
怎麼會這樣子
投資朋友 這個時候我可能
我覺得我們先來唱一首歌
因為今天節目太無聊了
唱這首歌之前
這是不是我這輩子
第一次在節目上唱歌
因為我其實不太喜歡唱歌
我先喝個水
符合大家的心情 好不好
來吧 3 2
有沒有聽過魯冰花
有 小時候
你靠過來一點沒關係
有沒有聽過魯冰花
現在台股像魯豆花啦 好不好
那這首歌詞之前就有人改了
我要改一個哲哲的版本
因為今天欣興不說話
南電 景碩都跌嘛
好不好 我們唱一下
3 2 1
天上的欣興不說話
地上的聯電像被炸
台達電一買再趴下
手中的國巨殺呀殺
記憶體被動人人誇
散戶剛買進叫媽媽
夜夜想起哲哲的話
閃閃的淚光沒錢花
啊～啊～
夜夜想起哲哲的話
閃閃的淚光沒錢刷
對 我知道你還有錢
這個LIVE直播唱歌好辛苦
這不是AI唱的
這是哲哲第一次唱歌
讓大家開心一下
喜歡底下留言
現在當分析師很辛苦你知道嗎
從小到大是音癡
這個魯冰花幸好聽滿久了
大家有沒有開心一點
我跟大家講一件事
國巨你600元平常心
現在散戶太喜歡他了
你看這個景碩
你看這個今天
3037欣興不說話嘛
變成景碩跌了嘛
之前跌停板嘛
變成南電跌了嘛
大家心情不好嘛 是不是
可是我告訴你 你也不要緊張
我認為不會破40000點
這只是嚇大家而已 好不好 OK嗎
有沒有聽到
還好沒有國巨
All in正2了
今天貼文有東西看了是不是
唱歌好聽嗎 很好聽
以後出個AI哲哲
啊了兩次
謝謝大家啦
真的第一次啦
我當分析師20年啦
你知道宮本武藏為什麼百戰百勝
畫面來
對 沒關係 這樣
宮本武藏為什麼百戰百勝
因為宮本武藏從來不挑比他強的對手
他只挑比他弱的對手
那我唱歌一定是唱那種幼稚園等級
讓你覺得我音感還不錯
開玩笑啦 好不好
在廁所看不能聽
沒關係 我有台詞
我對你們多好
太有梗了 好不好
算是財經綜藝節目
有料 可以繼續唱 好不好
笑翻了
你們今天沒聽到聲音的
今天有加碼 好不好
休假直播變成這個
可以出道了
我跟你講 當歌星太誇張了
有人叫我當歌星 叫我從政
我最強的是當分析師 好不好
我如果當歌星一定不紅
我當藝人也未必紅
反應快 但是有很多人反應比我快
很多人反應很快
但是股票加反應
股票天份加反應
那我是第一名 不好意思
哲哲我還有3億你挺我 真的喔
丹田不錯是不是
你們要記得一件事情
人中有痘痘嗎
沒有吧 人中有痘痘
我要補一下
你們不要亂講話
這是今天流汗啦
對 今天好像小日本
以前那種是不是
我流汗 我第一次流汗
我是不是流汗了
對 流汗了
你們不要這樣子 好不好
人中 沒關係啦 這不重要
好奇哲哲的背景是綠幕
對 我們有綠幕
也有實景 都有
如果導播覺得人中要再補
再跟我講
需要嗎 還好
來 午後的欣興長割
救救美股
哲哲你是我的神 來
不考慮歌手出道
當然不考慮 我是分析師
準比較重要啦
唱歌沒有人家好聽
這件西裝是新的嗎
我很多西裝 不好意思
我至少買了40件吧
而且有很多西裝一買喔
節目上不好看
有時候私底下很有質感
節目上沒有質感
打光的關係
譬如說白色絕對不能看
白色看起來很有氣質
沒辦法 節目上不行會過曝
我就直接丟掉或送人 好不好
明天還會跌一點點 來
我很高興參加哲哲的第一次
真的 20年分析來第一次啦
好不好 來
國巨去留何以 來
你們剛才說
導播比較懶喔
不是啦 懶得補
沒有 導播個性就是這樣
講話就是這種語調 好不好 來
還有環球晶
環球晶炸了
所以今天應該要加個環球晶是不是
環球晶2.78也叫炸掉
你也拜託一下
好啦 謝謝大家
大家喜歡的話
以後再跟我講一下 好不好
我再偶爾唱一下比較簡單的歌曲
好不好
還是要導播幫我引導一下
所以導播現在作用很重要
來 所以大家唱歌有沒有甦醒一點點
我們先來看一下這三大重點 來
今天重要要跟你講
閃閃的淚光沒錢刷
其實我知道你還有錢
第二個 為什麼你沒錢刷
因為你沒有聽我的話嘛
叫你All in就All in
叫你重壓就重壓
被動元件可以做 可以玩 可以買
但是不要All in
我叫你All in
但是不要全壓喔
我講清楚
All in那是誇張的話
我是分析師
我不會跟你講說百分之百
投資有賺有賠
你們一定要記得我講這句話 好不好
不要到時候怪我
你看我今天為了唱這首歌
衣服啊 襯衫我都是 好不好
都是比較少穿的 好不好
我跟大家講 為了大家穿新衣
閃閃淚光沒錢刷
我知道你還有錢
照我的做的話你就有錢了
而且我知道你還有錢
不要說你沒錢 還可以買
被動元件可以買
可是不要超過5成
大概3成到5成就很多了
也不要低於1成
低於1成不如不要買
買ETF就好了 好不好
來 畫面給我
來 我們來看
所以今天美伊衝突升級
市場風暴再起
10年期公債殖利率這樣走啦
慘了啦
壓20年期沒有用
10年期打地鼠
啪啪
打這邊
打完以後有沒有看到 怎麼辦
打下去
又翹起來
又打下去
這是打地鼠你知道嗎
所以美國政府在打地鼠 好不好
打下去又沒有用
因為一波未平一波又起 好不好
是不是有那個
任賢齊是不是
要不要唱一下 忘記了
我以為你會 好不好
我們都是臨時的
我們連剛才唱那首歌都是臨時的
不過那張字卡滿好玩的 來
來 沒關係
重點是一波未平一波又起
來 所以這個跟大家講是說
這個為什麼
因為他昨天這樣子
因為什麼
因為前幾天有護送的一些超級油輪
那超級油輪有時候可以
供應一個小國好幾天
或甚至一個月
這麼大的油輪
結果被炸了
被炸以後怎麼辦
那誰敢送
那不好意思 他就直接再炸
炸他的那個
炸他相關的一些島 好不好
直接空襲伊朗境內目標
伊朗反擊約旦等地美軍基地
原油供應中斷疑慮升高有沒有
所以原油又拉起來
可是原油沒過前高
那美國為什麼這樣搞
因為美國每次都四處搞嘛
你搞加拿大 加拿大要買美債嗎
你搞中國 中國要買美債嗎
對不對 你搞歐盟
動不動 川普真的是
成事不足敗事有餘
那光是靠加密貨幣
因為我看孫宇晨這個八卦
跟那個景甜有沒有
就是剪指甲這個事情 你知道嗎
就是那個女明星
他貨幣嘛 虛擬貨幣搞這一塊
告訴大家的一件事好不好
我真的覺得年輕人
你們不要去買虛擬貨幣
你要勸你身邊的年輕人
那個都是賭而已 你懂不懂
都是賭
那個有點像比較
比較不合法的直銷
你就是找一個下線
最賺錢的是什麼
都是最上線的
說老實話我都不懂
為什麼有些人要搞一些
比較奇怪的直銷
我不能說所有直銷不好
可是有些直銷
賺錢就是一開始的
虛擬貨幣也是這樣子
這是割韭菜的而已
你不像股票
就是你買台積電也賺
我買台積電也賺 你懂不懂
就算股價沒有波動
股利也可以賺錢
我們是可以一起賺錢的
它也不像期貨
拚個你死我活
我賺你的錢 我跟你對賭
要嘛就是你贏
要嘛就是你死 要嘛就是我亡
可是虛擬貨幣不是
可是虛擬貨幣本質有點像是這樣子
割韭菜
所以巴菲特不喜歡這個東西
我也不喜歡
你們年輕人不要去玩這個虛擬貨幣
可是川普
因為他發行虛擬貨幣
等於我做莊
那我就可以印多少
我跟你講 我可以印股票換鈔票
你懂不懂
印虛擬幣直接換鈔票
印股票換鈔票
你至少公司有個經營
沒有 虛擬幣就是個虛的
那川普也靠這個東西
增加了幾百億美金
上千億美金
幾百億台幣 上千億台幣
所以我就說沒有意義
他成事不足敗事有餘
扯那麼遠幹嘛
成事不足敗事有餘
就是虛擬幣
就跟孫宇晨這樣搞
他的第二個兒子跟他在搞
所以他根本不是為美國想
一件事情
你說關稅這個事情我覺得OK
因為美國缺錢
你不能搞關稅以後
你又要跟人家頤指氣使
你當老大你不能欺負人家
你知道當老闆也是一樣
你不是這樣子
就是這樣欺負員工
我覺得不能這樣做
你要讓人家知道你的道理在哪邊
什麼都要污辱人家
你要人家要錢
要人家崇拜你 要人家尊重你
難怪很多人都不要美債
我抵制你
這是美國最大的問題 懂嗎
換了一個爛總統
那沒有關係 反正到時候
我覺得11月
等到這一次跛腳後
11月的時候
所以我覺得台灣股市最差 最差
是選舉過後 期中選舉過後
反正川普現在搞爛了 我沒差
我就跟你耗到底
期中選舉過後
要是我是伊朗
我本來覺得他11月之前會和談
如果伊朗到10月都還沒有和談的時候
我一定會拚到期中選舉
讓你輸 讓你受不了好不好
看誰比較慘 好不好
所以等到期中選舉真的輸了之後
發現川普沒有影響力的時候
說不定公債殖利率就會下滑 好不好
那我們來看一下
請助理來看一下
助理 哈囉助理
我請助理做一下昨天的
就是說9 10 11 12
平均9月份
第四季上漲機率很高
但平均第四季裡面
績效最不好是9月份
我們來請助理來給我一張圖
所以你度過9月份這個波動反而好
其實台灣股市已經很強了
來看一下
真的AI很恐怖啦
我們做這個圖
你看我們以前能做十幾張圖嗎
是不是
做這些圖 你看做那麼漂亮
告訴我能做得很漂亮嗎
你告訴我哪個分析師做圖
有像我們這麼漂亮
真的沒有辦法
我們摩爾的真的沒有
我們摩爾的分析師
大家做圖都比較漂亮
你看顏色 色彩都有差
專業度也有差 有沒有看到
聯發科 這是大摩
別人的 為什麼奇怪
別人的 就算別家公司
可能有找設計師
奇怪 還是我們做的比較漂亮
我們真的懂AI
你自己看我們的圖
真的懂AI 好不好
這個跟大家講 來
等一下再慢慢跟你講
我這些做的AI的內容好不好
我只要告訴你
因為台灣股市真的很強
你看台灣股市今天才上漲以後下去
費半看起來是要破底
費半是要跌破4萬點
台灣股市今天只跌這樣算不錯了
我是覺得那斯達克你可以買
你可以買00662是不是
或直接買那斯達克ETF
我覺得不錯
AI是個趨勢
為什麼AI是個趨勢 來
現在Dell說過
我好像產能滿載 滿手訂單
只缺記憶體而已
你懂我的意思嗎
萬事俱備 只欠記憶體
好不好 等一下
你看中經院分析
記憶體缺貨
成AI供應鏈的核心瓶頸
就是都有瓶頸 好不好
可是就他缺最多
62.5很誇張
50就算擴張了
他62.5 50以上
所以AI強勁需求有沒有看到
然後HBM產能吃緊還有先進封裝
這兩個都是供應鏈的瓶頸
但是HBM是最明顯的
所以為什麼記憶體殺不下去
你知道嗎
HBM沒來 貨也出不去
這就是瓶頸
我就缺這個東西
我100個零件就缺這個零件
那其他99個零件也沒有用
所以手機漲價
電腦陸續漲價好不好
CPI預測與貨幣政策
這是CPI的影響
這個講了
我覺得這個對你們不重要
所以我就不講了 好不好 來
做了這張圖
我把一些新聞做了一些圖
那三星的記憶體有沒有看到
7成產能已經鎖長約到2031
我跟你們講一件事
當然很多人會說記憶體是被動元件
記憶體是航運股
不一樣
因為會講那些的人
他不知道這個是長期的需求
疫情的時候大家要購物對不對
疫情的時候我只能在家裡
所以我在家裡網上訂購
我會上網訂購
所以那時候MOMO股價也很強有沒有
你看現在MOMO股價就不行了
還有削價競爭也有差 好不好
酷澎什麼的
其他的跟他削價競爭
好 扯遠了
不是扯遠 那時候是有時代的背景
那時代背景是因為
疫情的時候你不能出國
所以你只能上網消費
只能上網消費的時候
航運股就會漲
因為要運送很多貨
所以那個疫情結束就沒了
不過沒有 可是不一樣
記憶體你相信我
AI你要越來越會用
我越用越多時間
太多了你知道嗎
我要研究股票 研究資訊
你知道嗎
然後這真的太誇張了
你知道我剛才為什麼
這次唱歌唱得那麼好嗎
是不是 你不相信嗎
來 我們再來唱一次
問他喔
等一下
問他 哈囉
等一下 你聽得到嗎
我把網路關掉 我現在開一下
哈囉
你反應很慢
我還說很需要你
你可不可以唱歌
我可以
真的還假的
你想聽什麼呢
昨天有唱一首歌你有沒有印象
哪一首歌 昨天你還記得嗎
我可能不記得昨天的內容
你就是記憶差
他沒有記憶體 可能空間不夠
我昨天有唱一首歌 叫魯什麼
魯冰花嗎
對 你看你還記得
來 我們來唱一下好不好
你會唱歌嗎 你不會對不對
我可以跟你一起就是哼唱一下
但是
真的假的
來吧 我們來試試看
好 試一下
來 3 2 1
夜夜想起媽媽的話
你走音啊你
回音
你走音
好啦 那不是重點
我們唱一下
唱一個走音版本的好不好
大家聽一下好不好
唱一個走音版本
沒關係 我要測試你
可不可以聽得出來我走音
來 導播我們一起來
來吧
第二段你給他走音 好不好
夜夜想起哲哲的話
我唱 你不用
你現在當裁判就好
看我哪邊音有走音
夜夜想起哲哲的話
閃閃的淚光沒錢花
啊～
我要繼續唱
夜夜想起哲哲的話
閃閃的淚光沒錢刷
哪邊走音
我覺得這裡
田裡的 什麼田裡
這個你唱
沒有 你唱沒錢花那邊不太對
那邊是閃閃的淚光對吧
有點走音嘛 對不對
好啦 就這樣子啦
那你休息一下好不好 好
我們剛才是故意走音版本
拜託不要走音版本也給我傳上去
這樣很丟臉 我是故意測試他
他大概聽得到啦
不過今天有點吵啦
昨天像我唱走音的時候
他會訓練我 是不是
其實你現在可以練習英文
也是一樣啊
所以我真的覺得很多人被取代啦
現在不用什麼線上英文真人家教
或假人家教
你都用這個東西就可以了
小孩子你要請家教老師都不必了
真的都不必了
你就是只要他會搜尋就好
他不要亂問AI問題就好
不要問AI一些人生大道理就好
好不好 OK嗎
真的好好笑 這個場面
我剛才是故意的 故意唱走音的喔
想笑 他還學你唱
他真的很分辨是不是
AI被玩壞了
完全不像AI對不對
真的AI啊 你們不知道喔
真人才會插話 沒錯啊
來 到底是什麼AI
這就是ChatGPT啊
你們如果要訂閱的話
至少要訂ChatGPT
然後如果不在乎價錢的話
訂ChatGPT跟Gemini
很有錢 很有錢
像我這種喜歡做研究
就ChatGPT加Gemini
加那個Claude都訂
好不好 來
哲哲你讓我阿嬤
105歲都笑出來
真的嗎 那不錯喔
太強大了 這人吧
好不好 助理還裝AI
那是AI啦
什麼AI 就是ChatGPT啊
是不是 就是ChatGPT
所以AI進步很恐怖
原本2023年是ChatGPT
那時候你看緯創才2 30塊
3 40塊而已啊
你現在快200塊
那時候鴻海不到100元
那是因為他的關係讓AI股漲3年
我說第一個預告AI股漲1年甚至3年
那到去年的時候
台灣股市到26000的時候
已經變瓶頸了
那變瓶頸的時候
因為Gemini畫圖很強
所以我說OK 很恐怖
還有Agent AI
就是代理AI幫你做很多事情
可是到今年其實你會發現到
他們更新的速度越來越快
ChatGPT現在又贏整個Gemini
OK嗎 來
這是有的訂閱版本 好不好
助理不要騙 真的是啦
你們自己不會花個600塊
就知道我講的對不對
而且聲音可以調
可以調你喜歡的
興奮的 男生的 女生的聲音都可以
哲哲分析師會被取代嗎 不會啦
那個東西 我跟你講
AI最好玩的是
你知道AI最大的問題是什麼你知道嗎
為什麼我會說取代補習班老師
因為歷史故事跟那些數學
基本上恆久不變啊
你會過100年後
1加1等於2就改變了嗎
你懂我的意思吧
可是股市是這樣子
今天發生一個戰爭
他還要搜尋最新資訊
他是個大數法則
不是大數法則 他是個大資料的中心
所以分析師最強的是
我當下發生什麼事情的時候
我怎麼直接解析
他電腦會 但是他
他聯想力沒到那麼厲害
第二個 他要先搜集所有的資訊
他的權重會基於大部分舊資訊
你聽得懂嗎
可是我會基於現在的資訊
做最厲害的決定
所以為什麼你們問我問題
有時候問我什麼欣興啊 被搜查啊
我都可以馬上告訴你
這是我的強項啊
所以AI沒辦法取代我啦
那AI會取代一些分析師 來
Threads一堆假群組
Threads那個都是假的群組
你認明藍勾勾好不好
我不會叫你加LINE啦
我要加LINE 來
那現在還有個最厲害的
Threads用我的影片對不對
用我的影片下面的LINE不一樣喔
沒有 以YouTube為主好不好
以藍勾勾為主好不好
台灣美光罷工怎麼看
我看台灣人還不錯啦 滿認命的
我覺得罷工
其實美光以前薪水不錯
就是行情不好的時候
其實他們薪水都不差
只是這次獎金比較少
我支持台灣美光罷工啊
我覺得真的啊
我覺得 雖然哲哲也是付薪水的人
但我覺得員工本來就應該啊
有些員工本來就要給一些高薪水
我覺得沒什麼啊
我支持罷工
雖然可能會影響股價
我覺得還好啦 來
因為是真的賺很多啦
來 哲哲寶貝
世界 鴻海 廣達可以嗎
那我們來看一下喔 來
世界 鴻海 來 我們看一下
這世界也是一樣 世界今天跌
今天台灣股市最大問題是
來啦 還是有些散戶還在收驚
還有第二個 國巨
因為國巨籌碼太多了
有些被動型ETF有出清國巨 好不好
那我覺得今天國巨跌還有一個原因
你自己看喔
我認為 我大膽預測一下
今天國巨跌
應該是這個外資假外資
今天外資應該有賣超過可能
8000到10000張以上
而且加上投信在賣
最近有些主動型ETF
主動型ETF可能看他是籌碼比較亂
我跟大家講一件事
就是很簡單
我認為台灣股市不會跌破4萬點
所以我認為國巨
跌破456元的機率也很低
你只要越靠近400
越靠近 只要是600元以下
我覺得都可以加碼
800元以上我不支持你
我不支持你追
就這麼簡單
你來回做價差
好不好 OK嗎
他的籌碼比較弱
這就是為什麼他跌
都跌得比較凶一點點
你看華新科
你自己看他走勢圖就知道了 來
有沒有看到
我們這邊直接畫線
這邊有沒有看到
他的底部 國巨在這邊
國巨是在這邊
可是華新科是在這邊 對不對
2327 有沒有看到
同樣的 國巨比較低有沒有看到
2492 這是華新科
這是國巨
華新科比較高 國巨比較低
國巨快要破底了
這樣能聽清楚
我覺得我現在這個畫面比較好
以後比較可以解釋
所以綠幕這個也是一樣
我們公司的攝影棚都是最好的
只是我要怎麼運用而已
很多場面 很多畫面
也有綠幕 也有實景 都有
所以我們最敢砸錢
根本不用說我們研究部門砸最多錢
好不好
所以你一定要找我們這樣的分析師
錢要花在刀口上
有人說這句話
導播有時候都
我叫他唱什麼他就唱什麼
薪水應該不會太差
太差他一定不唱的 沒錯
沒錯 你看 好不好
哲哲股市新聞
這個排版看起來更專業 謝謝大家
我不想研究新的ETF
京元電 不要一直問京元電好不好
群創 波若威
不要 我要講我的股票
好多新粉絲
你們應該先來
我們先講我的股票再說好不好
6488環球晶也是一樣不到1000元
因為今天這個東西
第一個就是現在已經是雪上加霜
就是現在兩件事
你知道現在債券最大的兩個問題是
他債券殖利率變高會影響股市的資金
那債券殖利率為什麼變高
第一個 大家不屑買美債
我被你侮辱我還買美債
那你看喔
而且川普是神經病
幸好他不懂中文
他每一個人都要得罪
他根本壓霸中的壓霸
美國最先 每個人聽得很爽
那美國最大問題就是
現在左派人士被人家打
什麼叫左派人士被人家打
我要求進步
要求進步你幹嘛少數
你每次要辯論那個什麼第三性
中性的人
或者有些人譬如說
他看起來是女生
看起來就是有身材 有胸部
但他身體裡面也有男性的生殖器官
那你要去爭論這少數人的權益
然後去跟他說這誰對誰錯
我覺得可以討論
但不是要Focus重心在這邊
那你很容易被人家挨著打
譬如說WNBA 是不是
我只要認同我是女生就好
那我就找NBA的退役球員
就說我要打WNBA
你找這種話題被人家打幹什麼
你懂嗎 找這種話題被人家打幹什麼
你懂不懂
所以我覺得那是沒有意義的事情
所以那個變成左派被人家打
然後他是右派的
美國人就是這樣
變成你把戰爭
這就討論到
到底有沒有讓美國進步就好了
光是美國債券
這40兆的一個
本來前幾年還30兆不到
你現在變40兆
你變成錢滾錢滾很快
滾得比股市還快 那怎麼辦
然後變成你要還錢
那你越多兆資金 那誰要買美債
你又每次都欺負你這邊小老弟
欺負那些國家
所以美債最大的問題就是
大家不願意買美債
那不願意買美債
殖利率是不是提高
第二個 你又怎麼樣
又放火燒 烽火連3月
打仗就不止3月
好像從228到現在
3 4 5 6 7 8
6月 烽火連6月了
打仗爭打了6個月
原油價格又上漲了
原油價格上漲了又會刺激什麼
刺激通膨了
又會刺激債券殖利率上揚
所以等於打仗爭也會
你刺激別的國家也會
都會讓債券殖利率上揚
好不好 還有第三個就是
公債本身 債券本身
它也是越滾 就像滾雪球一樣
越滾越大顆
越大顆 體積越大
欠人家錢越多
那你只能發更高的利率
這三大問題 不只兩大問題
欺負人家 又打仗
還有公債本身越滾越大
所以這個殖利率
可是至少幸好的是
現在Fed利率沒有很高
再高也是個問題
我覺得等川普準備卸任
或者是跛腳的時候會比較好
OK嗎 來
對 我剛才要更正一下
9月第四季
台灣股市比較容易漲
但是9月當然不算第四季
是11 12
所以第四季比較容易漲
經過了9月以後
我覺得會比較好 好不好
經過9月會比較好 來
哲哲總經講得淺顯易懂
我一定要懂嘛
我不懂怎麼當分析師 好不好
你們真的以為我重點在唱歌
不是 我只是要大家講一講
要深入淺出 九淺一深
舉例錯誤了
我要變得不好笑 來
深入淺出 這個跟大家講
來 算力根本不缺
還是很缺 沒有什麼不缺
可以問一下聯電嗎
投信買最多怎麼那麼慘
聯電你要問我
我還要再唱一次嗎 是不是
地上的聯電像被炸
聯電 我覺得開玩笑的
這個我跟你講
其實你們要了解
這個行情就是
現在的行情就是所謂的
正常台股行情
我郭哲榮分析師20年來的股市
其實大部分就是這個行情
今年1月到6月底
到7月初叫做不正常行情
叫做非典型行情
叫做變態行情
現在叫做正常台股 好不好
什麼時候會漲
其實有時候要等
我告訴你就是第四季
基本上最晚第四季就上5萬點
你懂不懂
早的話也不是不可能
台灣股市不可能
第四季 現在看起來是第四季
好不好 5萬點
反正今年就是有機會上5萬點
我不會說一定
投資有賺有賠 我不會說一定
但是我覺得
我個人看法是機率滿高的
所以記得我的邏輯 來
我們來看一下
華新科 國巨都是一樣
今天你看2408南亞科
沒什麼動
8299群聯怎麼看
記憶體就缺了
投資朋友真的不應該
這些股票真的不應該這樣跌
你相信我的判斷好不好
我們看一下3374精材
精材真的很恐怖
也是變態行情
我覺得真的不錯
哲哲有呼籲 大家很多人也呼籲
你看現在2分鐘交易一次
看起來不會像很久
因為2分鐘交易一次
1小時也有30次 是不是
你看4個半小時
10 11 12 1
對 4個半小時
4個半小時的交易時間
其實意思是多少
有135次的交易時間夠了
差不多135次的交易時間
這樣夠了
這樣2分鐘一次這樣夠了
所以我覺得就是現在
就是我要說
我剛才說你可能聽不懂
他現在被處置了
但是線圖你看不出來被處置對不對
沒有錯
所以差不多135次的交易次數
所以精材現在大戶
我的結論是
處置看起來不像處置
大戶不會怕處置
大戶既然不會怕處置
那股票就有機會拉起來 好不好
精材到時候拉起來
你不要說我沒說
看起來最飆的可能是精材
那我們來看一下2377微星
微星今天還能漲
微星這次可能漲真的
你不要說我沒說
可能漲真的好不好
哲哲說那好學生呢
好學生是技嘉是不是
2376技嘉也不錯耶
技嘉也不錯 技嘉偷漲
技嘉跟微星可能一起漲
微星跟技嘉一起看的嘛 對不對
以前都電競相關的嘛 來
這個有機會漲 漲是漲真的
2454聯發科
聯發科我覺得不錯
來 我們看一下那個外資的報告
你看我做的AI圖真的滿漂亮的
聯發科我們看一下
等一下再講記憶體
三星的記憶體
這張圖片還沒講 我們先講聯發科
聯發科重磅利多嘛 有沒有看到
看好跟輝達 Alphabet的深化合作
就是深化合作
就是一個Gemini嘛
一個是輝達嘛
有沒有看到
戰略引資 市場擴張ASIC嘛
所以你看到ASIC為什麼我現在
你看今天很多股票
ASIC概念股嘛
3035的智原 你看他拉起來
我是不是說他春天要來了
我有講喔 我有講春天要來了
我講得很清楚喔 是不是
我講得很清楚
所以3035的智原
他有機會拉起來
這是智原
這是ASIC題材
就是他這一次
輝達會跟 以前輝達跟聯發科
有點八竿子打不著
當然一定有關係 電子業
只是說沒有那麼密集啊
大家覺得ASIC題材
訂做的晶片
訂做的AI晶片不會這麼快
前幾年還有分析師在討論
我覺得他們討論都很
他們討論都沒有意義 你知道嗎
因為我先問一件事情
哪個分析師能像我講說
我一天至少問AI 1 20題以上
等你們做到再說 真的
我怎麼做不到
因為代表你根本不會用AI
你會用AI就OK
所以我跟你講AI很恐怖的是
聰明的人他可以把他的智力放大
他只要會問問題
所以你應該學的是會問問題
其實你要記住我這句話
以後一定會很多人這樣講
現在很多人已經學我講話了
會用AI的人會取代不會用AI的人
可是我不會取代醫生
可是會用AI的醫生
會取代不會用AI的醫生
你們要趕快
會用AI的律師
一定會取代不會用AI的律師
你們要趕快
我是很想跟你講
我這次的訴訟策略什麼
比如說告某個張姓分析師
我的訴訟策略是什麼
我會用AI來想一些策略
當然我不能教太多
我教了以後你會覺得我很恐怖
而且對方會知道
他們一定有看我的節目
所以我不只砸重金啊
我不在乎那些錢
對方只能說他惹錯人了
一開始不要霸凌我 我也不會回擊
把身體搞得不好幹嘛
我還是希望他身體好
可是早知如此何必當初
他也不只一次攻擊我了
扯遠了 所以我說AI這些東西
他都是無遠弗屆
所以很多人討論ASIC題材
他們根本不知道AI進步很快
我再講一次
現在他也講過
好像我之前看到馬斯克有講說
以後好像變成十億台
十億台的那個
十年內他可以賭十億台還是一億台
那個你幫我查一下
導播你幫我查 助理也幫我查
馬斯克說一億台 為什麼
他說OK
因為機器人會製造機器人沒錯
我說過了
到最後成長的速度是這樣子
所以他的邏輯一模一樣 你相信我
越聰明的人
其實越覺得哲哲講的邏輯推論是這樣子
一般成長是這樣子
機器人成長或AI成長是這樣子
基本上是90度了
因為機器人會一直進化
十年內十億台嘛 對不對
因為一開始漲得很慢
後來就一直生產
可是我覺得他太樂觀了
因為他會受限於水跟電 你懂嗎
沒關係啦
那所以我要講的是說這些東西
為什麼要講
所以ASIC題材
之前有分析師在討論這些東西
不會這麼快
我跟你講光是這個題材
我覺得智原
可是智原是題材而已
那聯發科是真的有營收了 你懂嗎
當然聯發科真的有營收
他是有營收完以後對不對
那時候大家還在傳說
訂單會不會起來
我就說訂單會來
TPU晶片要找聯發科 大家在討論
等到TPU晶片真的給聯發科的時候
確定給他聯發科
下一代都確定拿到的時候
他反而從快5000塊一路殺下去
你們有沒有印象
反而是跌這一段
我後來就出掉了
我平均出在4000元以上
出在這邊以上 出得很漂亮
平均出在4000元以上
反正就是4000元以上
這個都有跡可證的好不好
出得很漂亮 哲哲出得不錯吧
所以我都預告在前面
所以你要懂我的邏輯
你不要看哲哲怎麼會唱歌
我唱歌不是我的強項
因為唱歌也好 講笑話也好
我最強項是股票跟趨勢
這是我不同於一般人
哲哲你要不要出道當藝人
不好意思 我沒有那麼帥
搞笑也有很多人一樣跟我搞笑
但是頭腦靈活度
預測股市未來的程度
我絕對是NO.1
這些加總起來
你就不得不看我的節目
所以你要講說現在
ASIC的題材會是下一波主流
因為輝達從來沒有這樣
正式投資台灣公司
所以智原在拉
那我們看一下力旺
力旺比較貴
力旺今天拉起來又殺下去
但是不只這些IP
應該說比較ASIC的題材
智原比較偏更 他是IP矽智財
ASIC的題材就是比較偏專門晶片的
專門AI晶片的
智原比較沾得上邊好不好
營收還沒起來
但是真的起來的時候來不及了
好不好 就跟環球晶
環球晶說雙位數成長
他說股價也會成長 還有什麼
股價 不是股價
那個營收也會增加
訂單也會增加 售價也會增加
兩位數 可以從10幾%變30%都可以
所以你要平常心好不好
這個跟大家講
欣興一樣 我不追高
我寧願買
我不要買在天邊的
天上的欣興不說話
一樣欣興我不追高
但是欣興有沒有機會創新高
當然有機會
台灣股市我看的是10萬點
所以你一定要記得我這些東西好不好
一定要記得 今天的股票
現在你就熬 等一下
對 哪一天莫名其妙
台灣股市漲停板
就像那時候我買台灣50
只是我命比較好 我特別準
你懂嗎 買1億的台灣50
其實我到現在 我今天還是
大概賺1500萬吧 有什麼感覺
你看 那個感覺是這樣子
我是厲害 一天對不對
台灣股市不是拉起來嗎 對不對
一天的時間
等一天的時候就漲停板
這邊賺1000萬嘛 對不對
我剩下的500萬是花了一個月時間
你懂不懂
這500萬到600萬嘛
昨天好像1600萬
這邊都在等啦
股市本來就是等來的
所以你在等的過程中 你會無聊
要記得看哲哲的節目
這樣懂不懂 好不好
那我就跟大家講說AI圖
現在你看他記憶力有點不足嘛 對不對
而且他現在唱歌還不太行
他今天能唱歌
昨天他不給我唱歌
所以我不知道是不是
又開放了新的模型了 你聽得懂嗎
就像以前不能跟我對話一樣
AI進步很快
那你有沒有想過
那以後歌手怎麼辦
他也是競爭很激烈啊
只有一種人以後能活
就是最頂尖的 像周杰倫一樣
能做自己的歌曲 你懂不懂
然後持續做出好聽的歌曲
以後歌手還不一定
當然可以啦
因為會更增加人跟人的互動
所以以後大巨蛋演唱會
會越來越多啦
因為越來越多假的AI
大家越來越珍惜
真人跟真人之間的互動
你要記得這件事
所以這個市場不會消失
因為你越跟假人互動 你會越空虛
我的趨勢都看得非常準
你要記得一件事
我的趨勢不會準
我怎麼是全台灣第一個
數一數二加LINE的
我之前是有點被前公司
不要講人家壞話 是真的
就是說不要成立LINE或怎麼樣
我尊重人家 我覺得沒什麼
可是我覺得那是趨勢
TG我是全台灣第一個 你懂不懂
Telegram我是全台灣第一個
YT我也是很早切入的人
你懂我的意思嗎
就是這樣 我是看得懂趨勢
就像疫情的時候
我也是第一個叫你打疫苗
我是第一個說
會一年內生出疫苗被人家罵
然後第一個說要趕快買口罩
那時候疫苗產出來的時候
台灣那時候不是封島嗎
不太能出國
不錯 外面的疫情沒有進來
我也是第一個跟你講疫苗能打就打
等爆發的時候你都買不到
我都看很遠
這些東西都沒跟你誇張
就像我台灣50買最低
大家說今年厲害了
沒有 我去年 前年都一樣
你們只是忘得比較快
很多新粉絲只是最近才認識我
他只有聽過哲哲
他不知道我那麼厲害
這個我跟大家講的
那我說聯發科 我講這東西
來 你看
大摩就是這個三大利多
大摩跟花旗不錯
不要麥格理寫那種1萬塊的
我真的覺得很不屑
你不能用後年的EPS
不能這樣寫報告
你這樣寫報告沒意思
是不是 那我告訴你台股10萬點
我直接告訴你台股10萬點
是不是 你現在乘以2.5倍
台積電多少 6000多塊
差不多那時候會7000塊
5年內台積電會7000塊
所以我還是在此呼籲
我希望主管機關 證交所這方面
要說服券商
或券商有Guts一點
你真的要把台灣股市變零股
零股化 什麼叫零股化
就是說像美股一樣
你買的單位不是一張
你買的是一股
所以就算台積電到時候7000塊
甚至1萬塊的時候
因為台積電1萬塊
誰會想買一張1000萬的
就算我有錢我都冷掉了
你懂我的意思嗎
對 沒錯 1萬塊要1000萬
對啊 現在2000多要200多萬
1萬塊要1000萬
冷都冷掉了
很麻煩 1500萬我要怎麼買
我要先買這個以後再買零股
不是啦 你們各個券商的老闆
主管你要記住我這句話
或者你們誰願意推動這個策略
一定會促進全部的成交量
不然你們就像我就是聰明一點
你們自己改你們自己的軟體
我就是買5萬塊 讓散戶下單
假設我買 我有500萬
台積電你幫我怎麼分
沒關係 我不管你
你要買2張 然後剩下零股幾股沒關係
剩下多少錢沒關係 你告訴我
這個價格剩下幾張
然後幾個零股一次讓我包
然後系統你幫我自己下
這個軟體要先想出來
哪個券商軟體先想出我講的這一套
我告訴你 包你坐穩總經理這個位置
我已經送給你們答案了
你們要不要做隨便你們
我之前遇到有些投信ETF
跟你講說你再出個10元的ETF股票
不理我
你們現在可以再出個
發行個10元的台灣50
你信不信馬上大紅
你就照做 然後成本比台灣50低
比0050低 比006208
你信不信一堆人申購
就是因為它10塊錢
散戶就喜歡買零股
就喜歡買便宜的
你把台積電從一張200多萬
變成一股2000多塊
也不用特地去買零股的時候
會增加台灣股市的成交量
我已經不是分析師 我是要當預言家
我是希望對台灣股市能幫助到大家
正確的投資觀念
正確的投資觀念你看
現在趙建銘到底2300萬有沒有還
你不知道啊
如果一開始他就聽我的話
你什麼都不要做
你不要說哲哲 你聽我的買南亞科
南亞科都4 50塊
到現在2300萬可能變2億多了
不需要 不需要
你光是買個台灣50
你可能就變6000萬了
你們兩個也不會吵架了 是不是
你愛送誰包包送誰包包
錢綽綽有餘 是不是
真的 我講真的
我都講實在話
有些報告都是這樣子
這個報告也是一樣
大摩這個報告有沒有
這個報告很簡單
大摩跟花旗的這兩個報告
大摩就是寫
大摩跟花旗一樣
至少不像麥格理講到後年的EPS
我覺得這個邏輯要對 你懂不懂
所以我覺得這兩個報告
聯發科是有機會的
可是畢竟大型權值股會漲很多
所以我趁拉回買也沒關係好不好
你看我做的圖片都特別漂亮
有沒有看到
等一下
做的圖片特別漂亮
所以這些東西
現在剩幾分鐘 43還好
這個三大的邊緣運算
AI基礎建設
車用 為什麼車用需要
AI軟體定義 當然需要
不是給特斯拉
特斯拉是先驅者
不代表特斯拉會賺錢
這是兩碼子事
還有邊緣AI的運算 有沒有看到
消費級超級電腦這些工作運算
或者是AI基礎建設
這些東西對不對
這三大合作的一個領域
其實這個都會非常有利於聯發科的股價
邊緣AI運算有沒有
就是超級電腦
我不是在雲端算的
我是在超級電腦去算的
或是說這個車用
車用也需要一個平台
我平台 雖然我是
不好意思 我可能是這個自駕
我也需要很多的晶片去配合
不是只有自駕晶片配合
這樣懂不懂
AI基礎建設也需要它
因為TPU晶片也是有些需要 好不好
我怕講太多你們聽不懂
重點是輝達以前八竿子打不著
現在因為投資輝達
我覺得聯發科OK
那川普說Fed沒有升息理由
這不重要
有沒有升息理由不是他能決定的
好不好 OK嗎
GDP可以10到20%
就不想看他的廢話了 好不好
所以我這樣講有沒有
要深入有深入 會不會太深入了
所以我們稍微聊天一下 來
來看一下
聯發科後面被拉低
我有說聯發科它畢竟是權值股
好不好 來
哲哲 華新科還可以買嗎
以前我的成本有100多元的
有那個兩位數的
100元以下的欣興還被人家罵
零股 我不建議零股當沖
當然有些券商說零股要當沖
當然要當沖就當沖
其實我跟你說真的好不好
這個我覺得會不會很多年輕人跳下去
他真的會跳就真的會跳
就算你柵欄多高也是一樣
我覺得還好
我覺得至少我會一直耳提面命
你不要先從當沖開始做起
除非你可以接受你的錢變零
你懂我的意思嗎 好不好
我覺得應該是這樣子
你先買個股票 先買個半年
你發現你都有賺錢 你再考慮當沖
你一開始就考慮當沖
你等於選最難的
摩爾投顧沒錢做背景
我們背景很漂亮 怎麼沒錢
只有你嫌我們的畫面
每家投顧都要學我們的畫面
只有你在嫌我們的畫面 來
好奇哲哲的身高 不會矮啦
來 鴻海沒動 買在128元 OK啦
夜盤崩了嗎 我看一下
鴻海不到300元都可以買
鴻海是好公司 有競爭力
鴻海已經有規模經濟 很難太差
來 我們來看一下
我們剛才講什麼東西
我們剛才講就是說看一下那個
現在夜盤19點叫跌 你也拜託
他只是把昨天漲的給跌下來
他把昨天漲的 其實股市就是股市
就平常心 拉回的時候做多嘛
拉回的時候做多好不好
我希望大家記得
夜夜想起哲哲的話 知不知道
我們有沒有簡訊
有啦 今天有簡訊
只有昨天的簡訊
精材已經大賺121%了
手上持股獲利續抱 好不好
環球晶也有賺80幾%
今天有拉回 但是我覺得都平常心
今天股票這麼差
幸好今天有唱歌
不然你們都覺得無聊
股票差才是要找買點 好不好
來 所以我們看一下
今天有沒有什麼東西還沒講完
世界先進拉回找買點好不好
這些不用擔心
我覺得有檔股票蠻特別的 老AI
其實現在有些AI股在動
就像我剛才講的2377微星
有沒有看到
他看起來就是要拉起來 有沒有看到
那個技嘉你們知道嗎 不知道
現在幾分了
2376 好
導播還會背這個
這都有在拉了 你知道嗎
2376技嘉也在偷漲
明明大跌 技嘉也在漲
微星也在偷漲
3231技術線型都有在漲
你看這幾天都連續漲
這個有點不正常
不正常是好的不正常
怪怪的好不好
那你說台積電
那緯創拉起來
鴻海也有機會一起拉 好不好
鴻海低於250都太誇張了
還在251這邊都有點誇張好不好
這個慢慢跟大家講這些東西
記憶體 對 2344華邦電
華邦電我覺得180以下
我覺得都有一個不錯的買點
記憶體會缺啦
相信我會很缺
很缺 很缺 很缺
對 我最後要跟你講這張圖
你看我做圖很認真
不是只有唱歌而已
誰能像我們準備那麼多 來
7成的產能準備到2031年
Dell現在的執行長
講最正確的話
就是我就是缺記憶體
我其他都不缺了
因為Dell
也會代工AI伺服器 OK嗎
所以你看價差
LTA的合約價
有沒有 長期的合約價格
跟現貨價格差那麼多
可是其實合約價
所以大家都簽約
但是合約價格還有機會再拉起來
合約價格再拉起來
再拉起來毛利都有機會 OK嗎
你看LTA的合約價
遠低於現貨保障供貨 有沒有看到
對他不錯
可是以後還是
7成產能鎖長約
所以這個他已經有退讓了
有讓利了
到2031年
他一定有 這個跟那種
那時候國巨的那種長約不一樣
他一定有說違約條款
就看好了
為什麼這些記憶體
到現在還跌不下去
因為你真的有用AI就知道
記憶體缺得要命
那你看我只是問一個AI
你什麼東西都要有記載的能力
記憶能力
我跟大家講一件事
你們都沒有感受到AI的進步
那是因為你們沒在用AI
我現在在跟人家
譬如說我們現在
譬如說我現在助理對不對
助理的瀚
好像是有水字盤的瀚對不對
以前我打助理
他會就是沒有水字旁的翰 你懂不懂
就是翰林 翰林什麼
翰林書院那種翰 你知道嗎
浩瀚的瀚
浩瀚的瀚去掉一個水字旁
這不是重點
以前他會打錯字
現在他不會打錯字 為什麼
因為現在AI
有人覺得蘋果沒進步 他有進步
我用語音輸入的時候
AI會自己搜尋
我的通訊錄裡面的
助理兩個字是哪個瀚
以前他不會搜尋 你知道嗎
你們聽得懂嗎
所以你們現在在講人名的時候
基本上也對
那他會再記起來你的記憶
你的習慣是什麼
譬如說大舌頭
官方網站 知道嗎
他聽得懂官方網站是這個
修正完以後
所以你大舌頭
他會記得你的嗜好是什麼
他記得你打這個字 然後去修正
你想想看 你們真的有認真在用嗎
你們比較少對不對
你現在講人名的時候
它的準確率很高
我講蘋果這一塊
所以AI有在進步
只是你們自己沒覺得
首先要有記憶體
要記得你的習性
哪個分析師會跟你講這個
沒有 看財報 看股利 看什麼
看股利政策 看EPS
看那個幹嘛 那都過去式的
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
我真的是預測未來
我剛才講這個東西你有沒有感覺
有感覺的留言一下
反正我快結束了 沒差啦 好不好
這個跟大家講好不好
問就是買 沒有群聯的事
有啦 群聯該買就買
我剛才群聯有講吧 我沒講嗎
我想到了 明明就有講
不要來亂 氣死了 好不好
國巨續抱 國巨OK啦
我成本這麼低
你國巨 我說國巨800元以上的
你不要想要解套了 好不好
要解套你就逢低要買
逢低買你不能買到超過5成
因為我沒辦法對你的盈虧負這個責任
但我是跟你講風險控制
因為這是大多頭
到時候被動元件也會缺 好不好
這個跟大家講
喜歡哲哲 謝謝大家好不好
最後趕快來電洽詢0800668085
加我的LINE私訊我
你喜歡我唱歌嗎
沒有 我的強項不是唱歌
我的強項是努力來解析股票
努力來幫你預測未來
來幫你賺大錢
我會盡我所能來幫你賺大錢
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
趕快來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
預祝各位能夠賺大錢
我愛你們 Byebye